was this just a random smash and grab
job or was ryan targeted because
somebody knew these were lady gaga stuff
i think 100 targeted i'll tell you why
for sure
first off because this neighborhood we
have celebrities it's a celebrity
neighborhood number one
number two we walk our dogs all the time
i walk my dog at 11 and 12 o'clock at
night it's safe here it's totally chill
number three how would anyone know that
that guy was walking those dogs
at the perfect storm i told you this is
the
perfect storm this particular what makes
it that no lights
it's not random there's no way because
it's we say it every night i deal with
bad energy bad things happening and
we've been saying it forever
and that's why there's no way they
completely knew what they were doing
because right here behind us is an
abandoned house across the street an
abandoned house so you feel like this
area was right before
celebrities hang out people walk their
dogs in this neighborhood you know what
i mean
it's too it's not random it's completely
yeah
it seems like you feel like this is a
safe neighborhood an expensive
neighborhood but they found a spot where
they could get him
well because they've been probably
watching him watching where he walks the
dog
how he walks in that's what people do
since you're a dog walker in the
neighborhood had you seen him were you
familiar with ryan no
never saw him i mean there's so many
people that walk in this neighborhood
and at night you can't really tell
people are everyone's very cordial
everyone says hi to each other that's
why it feels safe
we all look and say hi to each other we
all acknowledge each other
so we i don't remember ever seeing him
in the neighborhood but i could have you
know it's
did you have now we heard that he at
least for a period of time lived with
lady gaga
are you aware if she lives anywhere
nearby here or no i'm sure she does yeah
but i have no idea where she lives but
clearly she lives in the neighborhood
and and then that being said
he was just walking the dogs and people
do it all the time
so it's not who's gonna take somebody's
dogs unless they're worth money
did you i mean i don't know how well you
know your neighbors but has anybody said
if they
saw a face had any kind of eyewitness
information to the actual
only reason we know the whole thing is
because my neighbor read he so here's
what happened
bam bam i ran back in my house right and
then by that time the police told me to
stay in my house but they had
the car took off immediately with the
dogs and then reed saw the guy on the
floor and then read
read reads and pretty much saved the
guy's life
because reed ran across the street and
was like compressioning and doing
that's where i saw but i stayed back
just because there's a lot going on and
they don't need me in that situation
did you do you know if anybody has
security cameras that they'll provide
that footage to police last night the
police i think got all the security
police were amazing they were here fast
they took all of our
statements i saw the car so they were on
it we had all the helicopters
i saw the car so they got a they got a a
thing
they got a description of the car which
was what was the car what could a white
sedan i think like a nissan or something
like that you know
uh two-door both doors open on this side
and that's where the commotion was
happening
hold up shot him took the dogs and went
would i no because it was yelling for a
long time
that's the thing that got me out of my
house was it wasn't just ah
which usually gets me it was ah like a
long time and
very high pitched so i thought it was a
lady getting attacked
and that's when i ran out and then and
then that's when the scuffle and the
gunshot
so by the time i got out the screaming
had stopped so what happened was i think
they pulled up
jumped out tried to get the dogs right
and the guy was fighting with them
and then that's when he wouldn't let go
of the dogs and that's when they shot
him i spoke to someone who knows him
earlier and he said he was the type of
person who would have fought to protect
right and so i think the reason why we
know the whole story is because when
reid went over the guy said
those are lady gaga's dogs i'm pretty
sure that's totally what happened
because that's how the story
we all because they immediately reid
wrote me and he said oh my god you're
not going to believe this is who that is
and
so reed said when he got to ryan he was
talking he was conscious yes
yes yes but he's in bad condition that's
what they told i mean i thought he was
dead
i did i was totally shocked i'm like
what is happening right now
and i didn't know it was lady gaga's
dogs until later on what made you think
he was dead
he was just laying there no movement and
everyone was working hard you know it's
like that that working hard thing made
me feel like
the guy's done and i didn't know any i
just thought it was another like one you
know we have a lot of race car kids
driving here i just thought it was
something like maybe race car kids
you know shooting each other that does
happen around here but
i don't know yeah it's pretty intense i
mean really the most important thing is
someone got shot
and could be dead right now i mean i
feel bad for the dogs we need to get
those dogs back but someone actually got
shot over
dogs and over right now ransom
we know that's what's gonna is this
what's gonna happen now we're gonna
start
taking people's dogs for ransom it's
horrible it's horrible